it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr. Isaac BOE gosh who's
an infectious disease physician and
scientist based at the University of
Toronto and Toronto General Hospital
great to have you back on thanks for
having me back so we spoke recently but
everything has changed since we spoke I
mean the degree to which this has
continued to spread as someone who works
in this field are you surprised by their
trajectory since we've spoken
sadly you know we knew that this was
going to spread around the world we knew
that countries that were reporting cases
we're gonna have a growing burden of
cases and then we knew that countries
that didn't yet have cases we're gonna
start to see they were gonna start to
see cases very shortly and you know we
take a step back and look at the 30,000
foot view now you know most of the world
is affected and sadly some places are
more severely affected than others so
let's start there I have a bunch of
questions including from my audience I'm
not going through them in order of
importance but just to start somewhere
we're seeing very different death rates
in different countries and a lot of
ideas have been posited that there's two
different strains of different lethality
although I've not seen good evidence for
that so far that the populations are
older or sicker in some places what do
we know so far about the drastically
differing death rates yeah it's so short
answer is that I you know we don't know
as a medical and scientific community
but we have lots of different theories
and I think this will be fascinating
when the dust settles and you know a
year or two from now we have better
answers so I still think we have to
remain humble that we don't have all the
answers having said that I think there's
several factors that come into play here
this business of having several strains
of the virus I'm not entirely sure
that's going to play out I don't think
that's going to pan out in the end
viruses mutate all the time it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's more virulent
or more deadly than another virus and
there's likely multiple strains of this
virus as it spreads through different
continents it doesn't necessarily mean
that those viruses will cause different
severity of illness so that's one point
the second point is we know that the
populations that this virus is affecting
are different
and we definitely know that this virus
has more severe outcomes than people who
are over the age of 60 and especially in
those over the age of 80 so elderly
populations unfortunately are getting
significantly impacted by this infection
and we've seen you know for example
places like Italy where there is a
tremendous sadly at this tremendous
death toll and this is vastly
over-represented in in elderly people
and I think the third major factor here
is how robust the healthcare system is
and how robust a public health system is
within a country and we've seen
countries for example like South Korea
Singapore Hong Kong Taiwan where they
have fantastic clinical abilities and
clinical capabilities and also a very
robust public health system and they
really implemented strong control
initiatives earlier on in the epidemic
and and most of those countries I mean
everyone's coming out battered and
bruised but they're coming out less
battered and bruised compared to most
others so to follow up on on some of the
discrepancies that we're seeing before
we move on to testing early the data
from China suggested a significantly
higher death rate for men than women and
it was suggested that for cultural
reasons men are more likely to smoke in
China and that that might be the
explanation but it looks like that
discrepancy is persisting in other
countries without the cultural smoking
differences what what do we know about
that so far you know it's it's unclear
yeah and I don't have a good answer for
that yet and I that is obviously one of
the top questions is you know what are
the actual risk factors for having a
serious infection and death we already
know that age is a risk factor and that
medical comorbidities are a risk factor
you know if you're if you're sick to
begin with and you get this infection
you're more likely to have a more
serious infection and sadly more likely
to succumb to this infection but sex and
gender are still unclear as to how that
really manifests with this infection and
by virtue of being a male
is that also reflective of having a
greater you know in depending on the
country a greater probability of having
hypertension diabetes smoking or is
there just something about being male
that puts you on a greater risk of
having a more severe outcome it's not
it's not yet clear so let's talk a
little bit about testing we know that
here in the United States we have been
drastically under testing so no surprise
as more testing rolls out the number of
cases start to increase dramatically but
probably still drastically
underrepresented the real number of
cases we are hearing from some
governments that there's really no
reason to test people without symptoms
there's no reason to test people who are
not serious enough to be in the hospital
I want to hear your thought about that
in general but then also more
specifically most of the tests in the US
are not antibody tests which wouldn't
tell us if someone has had and has
recovered from the disease would the the
issue of testing everybody be different
if we were using an antibody test rather
than a pathogen test okay so there's
several excellent components of that
question that I think need to be
addressed the first component is the
degree of testing and I agree with you
completely there is tremendous under
testing not only in the United States
but actually in most parts of the world
so the actual figures that we see the
numbers that are reported are gross
underestimates of the true burden of
infection in just about anywhere in the
world now some places have more access
to diagnostic tests than others for
example if we compare the United States
with South Korea the United States is
testing relatively fewer people
significantly fewer people compared to a
place like South Korea so you know we so
South Korea's numbers are probably more
of an accurate reflection of the true
burden of this disease in that country
relative to the numbers coming out of
the United States but we get it we all
know that and and you know there's
various reasons for why some countries
have imposed
broader diagnostic testing than others
in the United States again these are
completely a political statement but
there was just some incredible
bureaucratic logistic and economic
hurdles that got in the way and that
continued to get in the way of providing
wide diagnostic testing and that
certainly has set the United States back
in their fight against the Cova 19
pandemic and it's really unfortunate to
watch that unfold in real time you know
but by no means are other countries
perfect there's many many reasons why
places
just just have not tested broadly the
next point I think that's important to
address is the utility of the test that
we're doing and I think we have to be
mindful of the question we're asking in
a clinical sense one of the questions we
asked is do you have this infection yes
or no because that is going to impact
our clinical manage and management of
that individual now and also in the
coming days
so the testing that's being done now
which is a which is a PCR test which
basically answers that question is that
virus present in you yes or no are you
infected yes or no that's an extremely
important test and that's the
appropriate test to be doing right now
and it's you know it's not the most
comfortable test they do what's called
the nasopharyngeal swab where they take
a big swab and they stick it all the way
into the back here nose people think
it's just like a little thing in the
front of their nose no anyone that's had
this knows that it's not the most
comfortable test to have but you got to
get a good sample and that's the way to
do it and that's the appropriate has to
be doing because that answered the
question yes or no am i infected with
this virus and that will impact clinical
management of that individual now and
also in the in the foresee Bowl days
days ahead what you're referring to as
well is what's called an antibody test
which basically asked the question have
you ever been infected with this virus
yes or no it doesn't tell you are you
currently infected with this virus it's
have I ever been infected with this
virus yes or no antibody tests are
typically blood tests and there are many
groups that are developing these
antibody tests
to determine if someone has ever had an
exposure to this particular coronavirus
yes or no these tests our heart to
develop because as you can imagine
there's lots of different types of
coronaviruses we have the common cold
which has there's four different types
of coronaviruses that are implicated in
the common cold plus we have this you
know kovat nineteen pandemic and you
know we've heard about MERS and stars
and other corona viruses as well so one
of the issues is is there cross
reactivity when we're looking for this
specific corona virus versus other
common corona viruses that cause the
common cold you know I think there's a
lot of research teams that are
developing these serologic tests these
are excellent tests to have I think at
the end of the day will be very very
valuable to use those tests widely to
see truly what proportion of the
population was affected by codisk Ovid
19 pandemic but you know in terms of
clinical management right now I don't
think the serology tests would be nearly
as useful as the PCR test that we're
doing right now
yeah I mean I guess we're my where I'm
thinking about it would be imagine that
you tested large portions of the
population and found that you know
imagine it's one and a half or two
percent of the population had the
antibodies would that be useful from an
infectious disease perspective in
thinking about the trajectory so to
speak yes absolutely
so I just want to distinguish two sort
of overlapping Venn diagrams of clinical
care and public health and of course
these overlap significantly but from a
clinical standpoint that antibody test
may be a little bit helpful but the PCR
test would be extraordinarily helpful
it's also available you you know in
indecent labs it can be available in in
a matter of hours so that PCR test is
valuable from that standpoint but when
we're looking at you know populations
and you know as you point out if we knew
that one population had a much greater
exposure to this virus compared to other
populations yeah it's also extremely
valuable from a public health standpoint
because that can
helped drive policy that could help
guide Public Health Policy that could
drive you know vaccine efforts when a
vaccine is available that could also
drive more focal public health
initiatives such as the physical or
social distancing measures that we're
all talking about and employing widely
these days so you know it's certainly
valuable information but I think from a
public health standpoint the serology
tests would be more valuable at this
point in time and from a clinical
standpoint the PCR is a little bit more
valuable we're going to go to a break on
our TV and radio show and podcast with
dr. Isaac BOE gosh but we'll continue
talking on our YouTube channel where you
can find the remainder of our
conversation so then we get into the
social distancing methods and questions
that are that are now coming up about
should you go get groceries or have them
delivered and how do you weigh or manage
the exposure of being in a grocery store
versus someone you don't know touching
your fruits and vegetables and this type
of thing at what degree at what level of
granularity do these decisions make an
impact so to speak yeah I mean obviously
these are very challenging questions
because it's hard to micromanage every
potential situation that may arise but I
think if people are mindful of the
general principles we'll all be okay and
the general principles are you know
physical distance I know we're talking
about social distancing but I think the
it's important words do matter and I
think we're switching to using a
physical distancing measure because
social interaction is extraordinarily
important and especially important
during these very difficult times where
we are physically separated from one
another
so when we're talking about these you
know physical distancing measures I
think as the public health officials
have been saying you know keep it to
about six feet if possible of course we
can't micro regulate every potential
interaction that may happen of course
people need to go out and get groceries
and you know fill their car with gas and
you know still live their lives with you
know as much normalcy as we as possible
but of course we also have to abide by
these rules to ensure personal safety
and also for public safety so
you know grocery stores many grocery
stores have adapted to this as well and
you can tell that many people are going
to grocery stores at off hours some
grocery stores I've seen have taken very
creative solution in the lineup they put
tape on the floor so that they know that
people will stand in line and be
separated by in an appropriate amount of
space many grocery stores have actually
put some hand sanitizer out and and
there's also the onus on the individual
if you're going to go a grocery store or
going to a public place to get you know
essential items that you may need bring
some hand sanitizer if you're in touch
with any high contact surfaces let's be
mindful of that wash your hands with
soap and water or use hand sanitizer be
mindful about not touching your face and
of course if it washed down any surfaces
in your home as well with you know the
appropriate you know bleach-based
solutions that that are that are
recommended so there's lots of things
that we can do that we can that
essentially mitigate our risk of getting
this infection while we practice our
physical distancing measures and
simultaneously while we go about our
day-to-day lives and and try care for
ourselves and our families so last time
you were on we talked about the question
of droplet versus aerosol is a is a
gradient so to speak it's not just it's
one or the other as that applies to for
example people in Boston as the weather
has been nicer are distancing physically
but are going to parks and bike paths
for example and for the most part people
know you you kind of stay separate as
you pass each other but invariably when
the bike path is three feet wide runners
are going to pass each other in the in
the opposite direction and they're going
to be breathing as people tend to do
when they are running what is the risk
of an infection in these outdoor
scenarios I've read it's as low as 1%
but it's like what does that really mean
does that mean if you pass a hundred
people you infect one of them I mean I
think there's a few points one is that
you know it's it's great to hear that
people are getting outside because truly
we're not locked in our homes right and
and you know these are tough times and
you know if we should be encouraging
going outside getting fresh air getting
exercise but of course still adhering to
these very important physical distancing
measures
and and again we can't micromanage every
situation that may arise and you know of
course joggers or bicyclists might pass
each other on the path and you know for
the fraction of a second that you're
passing each other on the path you know
I think the risk of transmission if one
person is infected is like exponentially
small you know we this is transmitted
through direct contact or through or
through droplets so you know if
someone's infected and like there's the
most unlikely of unlikely scenarios that
they're coughing in your face as you're
running or biking by you know that would
be that would be a problem but I think
that's a pretty unlikely scenario the
other thing too is if you're sick you
shouldn't be outside in the first place
it's really sick all the recommendations
are stay at home and and self isolate
for a period of 14 days so truly truly
if people abide by the public health
suggest not suggested rules of the
public health rules to really prevent
transmission in the community will be
okay it's just a matter of people buying
into these ideas so that goes directly
into the question of the folks without
symptoms or almost no symptoms I've seen
one study that says 15 to 18 percent of
cases have no symptoms there's an
Icelandic study that found half had no
symptoms that they could at least be
aware of where are we on that and don't
those numbers make it much more
challenging to say if you're sick you
shouldn't be out because there may be
you know NBA players who say I've tested
positive but I always felt completely
fine as an example yeah there's a few
points with that so I think the helpful
phrase is subclinical because if we say
the term subclinical it really means
that people are whatever they feel
either nothing or something
extraordinarily mild you know it's below
the detection of the healthcare system
you're not unwell enough that you're
gonna stop doing what you're doing
you're not unwell enough that you're
gonna go seek medical care and that's
the most accurate term because it's it's
a broad umbrella term that really
captures everything under that and the
term is subclinical and and therein lies
the problem because there is such a
large burden of subclinical
infection there are lots of people who
just don't feel that bad who are walking
around with this infection and these are
individuals who are likely contributing
to the spread of this infection
unknowingly in community settings and
this is why we have a pandemic this is
why it's extraordinarily challenging to
control this infection and and you know
in the same breath this is why we truly
need to adhere to these physical
distancing measures because if we truly
spread apart if we're truly mindful
about hand hygiene if we're truly
mindful about not touching our faces if
we're truly mindful about washing down
high contact surfaces like you know door
handles and and and elevator buttons we
can block many of these chains of
transmission and it's because there's so
many people out there with or
subclinical who just have mild to no
symptoms you know that are that are
facilitating transmission and community
settings if we can block that by really
spreading out last thing I want to ask
you about we for the last 10 or 14 days
have been talking about everything from
Ramdas of ear to a began the possibility
of chloroquine with or without
azithromycin HIV drugs with or without
interferon the wh o is now starting a
pretty large clinical trial that doctors
all over the world are going to be able
to to opt patients into if you had
specific thoughts about any of these i
would love to hear them but more more
likely i think it would be interesting
to hear how quickly might we start to
figure out which of these is a better
path rather than a less good path and
sort of what the process will be yeah so
got an hour I mean this is fascinating
and and it's just wonderful to hear that
there are so many potential you got to
be careful with our words potential
treatment options and I would add that
these aren't just treatment options
these are also being studied for
prophylaxis meaning if potentially
someone was exposed could they go on one
of these medications and avoid getting
infected in the first place now there
are well over a hundred and fifty
clinical trial
miles that are testing these various
compounds now the key thing here is
getting quality data there's a lot of
small studies that a Brit made huge
waves for example this chloroquine and
is it from Ison you know these are great
tiny little studies that are not
conclusive but are what we would call
them hypothesis generating like hey
maybe there's something here we should
look into this further but the real
studies are enrolling patients now and
these are what we would call prospective
studies that are blinded meaning you
know the people who are getting these
medications don't know which medications
are getting the clinicians administering
the medications don't know which
medications their miss administrating so
their placebo controlled or blinded and
prospective studies which is essentially
the gold standard for testing the
efficacy of various treatments and when
we have this quality data we will be
able to make much more meaningful
suggestions on how to treat and prevent
this infection how long does it take you
know surprisingly not as long as people
would think let's put it this way we'll
have this data available well before a
vaccine becomes available and these
clinical trials are actively recruiting
patients and you know I would be hopeful
that we might start to see early results
in the coming six to nine weeks because
you know sadly there's no shortage of
patients and these and many of these
trials are actively recruiting and to
have more definitive results in probably
closer to three months so on the
blinding thing the the w-h-o trials say
they will not be blinded although some
of the other ones are arthur caplan from
nyu said it's not ideal for them not to
be blinded but given the circumstances
it's still a good trial what does that
mean what what how do you balance the
lack of blinding with the sort of need
to start doing this yeah I mean I think
we should point out you that there's
there's so many trials that are ongoing
and each trial will have its own design
and each trial will have its inherent
strengths and its inherent weaknesses
you know in a perfect world many of
these trials would be blinded which just
adds into
of robustness to the trial and the
confidence that you have when you're
stating the results of your trial that
you know there's no unintended bias from
patients or from clinicians who are
administering the trial that gets you
know bled into the trial that way but by
no means if the trial is is isn't
blinded it doesn't mean that it wipes
out the results of the trial it's just
you know it's not a perfect design that
does not take away from the trial at all
and in fact any trial any prospective
trial is is extremely welcome at this
time and you know we're going to be
hanging off to every letter in the
printed manuscripts that come out from
this and we're going to be hanging off
of the every word of the individuals who
are recruiting patients for these trials
because we want to know if are they
working are they not working and this is
this is truly going to impact the
clinical management of you know many
many many patients absolute last thing
so with the chloroquine azithromycin
trial a lot of people are saying why an
antibiotic for a virus a my
understanding is that although it is an
antibiotic there are studies that seem
to be good studies that show in lung
cells it functions like an antiviral is
that the right interpretation
yeah sure to answer we have no idea it
might be it might be there also may be
what we would call immunomodulatory
effects as well so this is very
theoretical first of all we don't even
know if this works let's be clear that
study had well I think what 30 patients
with 30 small control group like it's
it's pretty hard to make definitive
conclusions from that study it's great
that it was done it's
hypothesis-generating it's sort of like
if we think about it in volleyball terms
that's the bump and now we need the set
and the spike so that's the that's the
very very very early part but but like
you know we can talk about theoretical
mechanisms I'm not sure it's gonna be
all that helpful let's see if this works
or not with with the with the larger
study we will indeed we've been speaking
with dr. Isaac BOE gosh infectious
disease physician and scientist from the
University of Toronto and Toronto
a hospital really appreciate your time
once again oh thanks for having me back
on